Trascrizione: Stefania Betti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
La radio:
(Musica)
La radio, probabilmente
tutti noi la conosciamo,
è quel media che abbiamo
sempre avuto con noi.
Quando siamo entrati in macchina,
a casa, in bagno, ovunque.
Ma probabilmente, noi conosciamo
la radio legata alla musica.
La radio è quel media
che ormai compie cent'anni,
e che oggi sta subendo un grande attacco.
Un attacco che forse è giusto;
ma probabilmente,
se apriamo un attimo lo sguardo
a livello mondiale
ci rendiamo conto
di un DNA, di un qualcosa
che.. se questo media
è rimasto così longevo, c'è un motivo.
La radio noi la conosciamo come il volume,
come il cambio di stazione,
come un contenuto.
La radio non è la musica e basta.
La radio non può essere paragonata
a Spotify, a YouTube o a TikTok.
Tutti i giorni mi sento dire:
“La radio sta morendo”.
Beh, penso che ci siano dei punti di vista
che noi dobbiamo, siamo obbligati
a prendere in considerazione.
La radio è live,
la radio ha un contenuto local,
la radio trasmette emozioni.
La radio non è una playlist
di Spotify o un podcast.
La radio non è on-demand.
La radio di oggi.
La radio analogica di ieri
è quella radio che la possiamo spegnere,
che ci può accompagnare,
è quella radio che ci dà un contenuto,
è quel brand che ci dà
una festa, che ci fa festa.
È un brand che ci individua.
Ma oggi, la radio è mono direzionale.
È uno di quei pochi media
su cui non possiamo mettere like,
che non possiamo condividere.
La radio, oggi, non vi traccia,
non vi ascolta.
Ultimamente sono usciti Alexa,
sono usciti numerosi dispositivi,
oltre al telefono che avete in mano,
e spesso si sente dire che vi ascolta.
La radio non vi ascolta.
Questa è la differenza.
Poi vorrei raccontare
perché sono così legato alla radio,
e ci sono nato dentro
per colpa di mio padre.
Io vorrei raccontarvi
una mission umanitaria
che ho affrontato
qualche anno fa in Kenya,
a circa 70 chilometri da Nairobi,
in un...
piccolo villaggio
di circa 2.500 persone
che mandava messaggi
alla comunità di Radio Maria in Italia
tramite un missionario.
Purtroppo [in] questo villaggio,
tanto per darvi un attimo l'entità,
le case sono fatte di fango,
la luce non c'è, il frigo...
Non hanno nulla, per conservare i cibi.
Non c'è cultura, hanno un dialetto locale,
si capiscono solo tra di loro;
e abbiamo portato
un trasmettitore, un'antenna,
tutti abbiamo lanciato il primo contenuto.
E per loro, anche se era
un contenuto religioso, era una festa.
Una festa perché sentivano qualcuno
che gli era vicino, che li aiutava.
Questa è la radio che salva la vita.
E quando dico che la radio è un media
che forse, probabilmente,
non deve essere influenzato dal digitale,
è perché è un'altra mission.
Costa d'Avorio.
Cambio del Governo.
La prima cosa che capita,
quando c'è un cambio, un movimento,
un cambio politico, un attacco di Stato,
la prima cosa che fanno
[è] bombardare il traliccio radio,
perché interrompono le comunicazioni
e poi il web, se ci sono
reti telefoniche, e la televisione.
Ma la prima cosa che si rifà?
Si ributta su una radio da campo,
perché costa poco, è veloce,
tutti la sanno usare.
Questa è la radio.
La radio cambia i paradigmi di un Paese.
Questa è la differenza della radio:
arriva dove gli altri media non arrivano,
perché non ha solo uno scopo commerciale.
E non ha bisogno di un like,
non ha bisogno di competenza;
e soprattutto, non vi prende
i vostri dati.
La cosa differente è proprio quella:
che la radio ti porta una voce,
ti dà un qualcosa in più.
Perché lì manca la voce:
non hanno i social, non hanno Instagram,
non hanno Facebook, non sono dappertutto.
Il mondo, se noi guardiamo sempre qua,
Milano, Roma, New York, Londra -
è tutto facile.
Ma bisogna girarlo il mondo,
dalla Papua Nuova Guinea al Vietnam:
è lì che bisogna vederlo il media,
e dove un media cambia un Paese.
Con questa.
È una semplice radio.
Ne abbiamo fatte qualche milione.
Queste le abbiamo distribuite:
oggi con World Family, questo progetto,
arriviamo in oltre 70 Paesi,
oltre 50 lingue, dialetti locali,
che è quella la difficoltà.
La difficoltà ad entrare
in contatto con la comunità.
Abbiamo aiutato i profughi dal Sud Sudan
a passare con un campo
che era grande quanto Copparo.
Abbiamo usato questa.
Non Instagram o una stories.
Però, forse, non abbiamo più bisogno,
perché oggi noi dobbiamo regalare
i nostri dati a tutti, l'ho sentito prima.
Noi se non sappiamo dove siamo,
se non ci tagghiamo,
se non diciamo cosa stiamo facendo,
noi siamo [persi] - è così.
Però si parla molto di detox:
di disintossicazione, di allontanamento,
di riprendersi la propria identità.
La radio -
in molti mi chiedono di pensare
come possa essere in un futuro -
La radio sta cambiando.
Domani io vedo una radio nuova,
una radio con la vostra musica,
che prende il vostro Spotify,
il vostro oroscopo,
con il vostro al podcast preferito,
il vostro programma preferito
dello Zoo di 105 o di Cruciani,
o il podcast che preferite.
Però non è vostra.
È degli altri, e voi la componete.
Ma qua c'è un problema:
che vi chiedono qualcosa in cambio.
La vostra identità; i vostri gusti;
le vostre emozioni;
quando avete alzato il volume;
probabilmente qualche parola chiave
che poi utilizzeranno
per rivendervi qualcosa.
Le tecnologie ci supportano,
sta arrivando il 5G.
Oramai non è un problema tecnologico,
non è un problema di contenuto,
è un problema di sapere
se noi vogliamo oggi cedere l'identità.
Tutto quello che abbiamo
noi lo stiamo regalando.
La radio ancora vi lascia liberi.
E noi, in Italia, siamo
i fondatori della radio.
Circa 94 anni fa, questo signore -
(Audio) del 1895, cioè all'inizio
dei miei primi esperimenti,
io ebbi la forte intuizione,
direi quasi la visione chiara e sicura,
che le trasmissioni radio-telegrafiche
sarebbero state possibili
attraverso le più grandi distanze”.
Lui, Marconi, a Bologna,
ha acceso circa un secolo fa la radio.
Aiutatemi a non spegnerla.
(Applausi)